hallo die ich bin ma s93 und ich wollte
wissen wie du die Zusammenarbeit mit den
Mädels von popsas findest das heißt
macht es dir wirklich Spaß oder ist es
vielleicht eher anstrengend ich würde
mich wirklich freuen wenn du meine Frage
beantworten würdest und ja bye hallo ma
s93 das ist ja krass also erstmal sage
ich dir es ist wie im normalen Leben es
gibt Tage die sind sonnig mit den
Popstars Mädels und hat man ganz ganz
viel Spaß und man fühlt sich total wohl
und man hat das Gefühl dass es richtig
glatt vorwärts geht und dann gibt es
Tage da es 24 Stunden nur Regen Sturm
und Flut angesagt bei den Mädels weil
einfach gar nichts funktioniert weil man
das Gefühl hat dass sie gar nicht das
verstehen was man ihnen beibringen will
oder das wohin man sie fördern will es
ist wie das normale Leben und zum
Schluss macht aber genau der Mix aus
diesem anstrengenden stressigen Tag und
den sonnigen Tagen das Schöne daran aus
weil wenn du zum Schluss dann sehen
kannst wie sich die Mädels entwickeln
und das siehst Du bestimmt in der
Sendung dann sage ich mir immer okay
auch die Regentage waren eigentlich für
irgendwas
gut soön prima vielen Dank sehr schön
das ist sehr interessant jetzt kommen
wir zu den
Briefen
genau